спеціальна місія спостерігачів
зазначає, що обидві сторони заборонили зброю
які люди мали протягом тривалого часу
ще треба відрахувати в
є зона безпеки і ця теж
використовувати
обидві сторони використовують заборонену зброю
і обидві сторони вважають мінські
угоди, зокрема про припинення вогню
який там надається, і відніміть його
важкого озброєння ззаду
у нас був один протягом останніх кількох тижнів
збільшення на 300 відсотків від забороненого
знайшли зброю і що має раніше
зосереджені в цій області
між кращим і буде ларс там
у нас дуже сильний ріст
бачив
більше половини всіх припинення вогню
травми та лінії контакту з землею
були спец
місія спостерігачів у цьому районі
зареєстрований досить принципово лежить
основна причина невідповідності
перемир'я, що ви сторони
забороненої зброї в безпечній зоні
також використовуйте та дотримуйтесь цих
Друга важлива причина полягає в тому, що
сторони занадто близько одна до одної
часто лише на відстані кількох метрів один від одного
відповідають за розслаблення
потім звільнений у бої
місія протягом року
300 тис. порушень перемир'я
встановлено
і наскільки відкритим, подивіться це зараз
нова згода на a
перемир'я на свята це
кількість поранень до кінця
рік іде вниз і що ви потім далі
початок року з новим імпульсом
тут можна знайти більше рішень для цього
довести конфлікт до кінця
дуже важливо додати, що
цивільне населення все ще дуже сильне
під цією сутичкою і розривається конфлікт
страждає ми бачили, що зараз
людей третю зиму в цих
конфлікт йти туди там створений
які третю зиму без газу
зараз у багатьох людей все ще є
самі труднощі щодо контакту
лінія для пересування і кожен цивільний
які ми бачимо по обидва боки
kontakt linie тоді повідомляє нам, що як тільки
є бажання і бажання є
що цей конфлікт перестає мати це
ми, діти, навіть казали нам
списки побажань до святого Миколая
Написали
на ньому немає іграшок
але наполягає, щоб у вас був спокій
був